bonjour kevin malacarne bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous sur
arte france pour parler de ce problème
le ségur de la santé aurait créé des
inégalités salariales
alors il faut contextualiser un petit
peu ce qui s'est passé c'est à dire que
le secteur de la santé intervient après
le début de la crise qu vide dans la
volonté de revaloriser un petit peu le
salaire des soignants quand on a vu que
voilà l'importance des soignants dans
cette crise et donc olivier ferrand qui
est nouveau ministre décide de
d'impulser se séduire de la santé et
injecte 19 milliards d'euros dans le
système c'est une réalisation importante
improbable dernier plan hôpital de
marisol touraine en 2012 s'était 2,5
milliards d'euros et celui de roselyne
bachelot s'était 7,5 milliards d'euros
6,5 milliards d'euros donc la disney
venir de route un gros effort qui a été
fait par par le ministre de la santé et
est donc ce segura permis à peu près 1,8
million de soignants des médecins des
infirmiers et des aides soignants pour
pour la plupart d'être revalorisés au
niveau de leur salaire d'environ 200
euros nets par mois
lors de l'ordre de grandeur est il faut
savoir que
cette augmentation touche aussi les
étudiants mais il ya quelques trous dans
la raquette est ce que souligne ce
collectif c'est que certains infirmiers
en fait qu'ils n'ont pas choisie alors
c'est ça une question de statut c'est
que son statut c'est à dire qu'en fait
en 2000
en 2009 sous roselyne bachelot il était
proposé aux infirmiers de passer
catégorie a ou catégorie b pour les
professeurs de la fonction publique et
donc certains ont préféré rester en
catégorie b voilà ils sont ils sont
minoritaires et c'est cela qui n'ont pas
touché pour l'instant la prime la
rémunération la différence entre
la catégorie b alors c'est sûr la
fonction publique comme ça il ya trois
catégories à b et c ils font la même
chose mais c'est des notions de statut
en fait et pour les infirmiers sont
passés bac + 3 ça crie ça suscite
quelques avantages ça suscite quelques
avantages en particulier alors pour la
catégorie à du coup il y avait une
augmentation de salaire et la catégorie
b permettait de partir plus tôt à la
retraite pour faire simple et donc
certains sons qu'on préférait garder la
catégorie b et c'est cela qui ne sont
pas rentrées dans la revalorisation et
ses soignants l'arrêt une partie du
moins qui dépose une plainte au haut
conseil d'état mais pourquoi avoir
oublié ses soignants de la catégorie b
écoutez je je je je sais pas ce que
c'était volontaire ou pas
en tout cas c'est sûr qu'il ya des trous
dans la raquette pour les soignants je
pense aussi aux libéraux est ce que je
connais bien secteur qui eux n'ont pas
été revalorisés
et donc du coup oui effectivement il ya
quelques trous dans la raquette ça je
pense que ça reste marginal mais il en
existe là ils sont 3000 un recours ça
représente sur les le personnel concerné
par cette augmentation aux catégories a
et catégorie des ça représente une
proportion de combien de personnes ba a
priori il y aurait 60 mille personnes
qui seraient concernées enfin qu'il
n'aurait pas permis de toucher cette
revalorisation
donc ça fait 3 3 milles sur les 69 qui
sont acquis sont concernés mais sur
contextualiser sur 1,8 million de
soignants qui eux ont bénéficié de
l'aide enfin sauf qu'ils font le même
travail et finalement lorsque leurs
revendications sont plutôt légitime
c'est plutôt légitime vous pensez qu'ils
obtiendront gain 12 je sais pas ce que
dira le conseil d'état c'est possible
qu'ils qui leur donne raison alors il
faut dire aussi que ces catégories d les
nouveaux entrants dans la profession ne
peuvent plus choisir le sait non non non
absolument en face c'était ça a été
décidé comme ça dans les dents les
discussions qui ont eu lieu donc avant
2010 c'était de proposer aux gens qui
étaient déjà en fonction soit la plus
torride b sur lequel hybris à est
désormais donc tous les to les informer
qu'ils rentrent sur le marché de travail
sont directement en statue leucate
gloria alors on va parler des infirmiers
libéraux dont vous faites partie qu'en
est il pour vous et bien voilà alors
nous on a pu bénéficier quand même de
certaines primes lors de lors de la
crise mais il est vrai que
il a le ségur de la santé ne touchez pas
les laissant on va leur dire 120000 un
fermier numéro 2 français aucune
augmentation à part les primes pour les
sources d'intention pas à parler à part
les primes quand il ya des primes pour
le pour le coc vide mais c'étaient des
primes ponctuelles n'y a pas eu
d'augmentation du tarif de des actes
pour les infirmiers libéraux en france
du coup est ce que vous estimez vous
aussi oublié du cesi je n'oublie du
ségur jeu à une certaine manière oui en
tout cas on n'était pas dans les dé des
discussions alors c'est vrai que le
ségur avait pour objectif de le
revaloriser les carrières hospitalières
on n'en fait pas partie mais je pense
que légitimement on devrait aussi
pouvoir augmenter la rémunération des
infirmiers le roller a précédé c'est
évidemment c'est des coups qui font
qu'il faut financer je sais bien mais à
une mobilisation ce sens non il ya pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de mobilisation
en ce sens mais mais en tout cas ça il
faut faire attention aussi comme parce
que j'en fais tout est imbriqué en fait
quand on augmente les salaires d'un côté
et bien si on n'augmente pas de l'autre
il peut avoir des problèmes de
recrutement dans les difficiles en ville
et aider voilà mais après c'était
c'était aussi je pense qu'ils étaient ce
qui avait été recherché pour quand on
dire conserver les soignants l'hôpital
mais en même temps il faut pas non plus
qu'il en manque en ville parce qu'il
faudra prendre bien en charge aussi les
gens à domicile est ce qu'il ya une
vraie différence de salaire entre les
infirmiers en hôpital et les infirmiers
libéraux
on a dit en tout cas beaucoup
d'infirmiers en hôpital préféré se
mettre à leur compte lorsqu'il n'était
pas suffisamment payés alors
on peut pas parler de salaires pour des
infirmiers libéraux on prend pas de
salaire parce qu'on parle de série
numéro 2 des rémunération à l'acte à
régler exactement comme comme les
médecins donc du coup on pilote plus
facilement sa rémunération ceci on
décide de travailler plus on gagne plus
voilà
de liberté plus de liberté donc si on
veut travailler plus oui on peut gagner
plus cake qu'elle est à quelle est la
situation avec le virus actuellement est
ce que vous êtes toujours autant
déborder alors alors pour ce qui le
concerne l'hôpital ou qu'est ce qui
concerne la vie
nous à
domicile
écoutez pour l'instant ça à 90 à
domicile les choses fonctionnent
correctement les professionnels de santé
font attention et protéger leurs
paupières leurs soignants quitte une
population vieille fragile il est à vous
si les vacciner aussi à domicile et puis
et
puis ben voilà on tient on tient le coup
depuis depuis le début de la crise et on
fait attention à nos patients et vous
sentez que la population adhère
maintenant à cette vaccination
oui globalement oui n'en veut
globalement dans la très grande majorité
des cas les patients se sont fait
vacciner alors il ya des sites certaines
situations difficiles on a les personnes
âgées qui pouvaient pas se déplacer dans
les centres de vaccination c'est là que
le gouvernement cible prioritairement
est ce que vous allez les chercher c'est
oui on essaie d'aller les chercher
ça a posé des quelques contraintes
logistiques mais voilà désormais on est
en les plus à l'aise pour pouvoir
vacciner les personnes alors il fallait
avoir les doses s'était passé ce n'était
pas simple parce que vous savez que les
doses de vaccin c'était par souvent par
des femmes sur l'eau et par l'eau donc
du coup qu'on va avoir une passe et
quand vous dois aller voir un patient
pour le val siné bien obligés d'ouvrir
un flacon voilà tu as posé dès sa pose
encore des problèmes logistiques mais
voilà on a réussi à trouver des
solutions avec les pharmacies qui
propose maintenant les seringues à
l'unité à la des petits et petites ips
comme ça qui nous permettent de vacciner
un patient par un patient dernière
question sur la troisième dose dont
parle beaucoup lui le gouvernement est
ce que est ce que ça avance là aussi
vous sentez que de ce que les personnes
finalement se disent je vais faire une
infection et puis ça fera office de
troisième dose c'est ce qu'elle dit
olivier verront récemment ah oui non je
pense que la d'appareils dans la
majorité des dans la grande majorité des
cas les les les français préfèrent avoir
une petite une petite injection qui dure
5 secondes que qui est d'avoir un
potentiel
dans des réflexions au co vide même si
heureusement au micro et et plus léger
que les autres les jeux de formes c'est
comme toujours plus facile d'avoir un
élection
l'attractivité de votre profession vous
êtes inquiets ou pas eu bah du coup ça a
c'est vrai que ça déstabilise et un
petit peu les choses pour tout vous dire
le recrutement est un peu compliquée en
ce moment
alors déjà parce que heath et ça c'est
un secteur qui est tendu la santé un
tout le monde a du mal à recruter un
édit compris y compris les hôpitaux et
c'est vrai qu'avec l'augmentation du
salaire à l'hôpital et c'est très bien
c'est une bonne chose un jeu je le
répète et du cou et le fait que les
hôpitaux ne libère plus leurs
professionnels c'est vrai qu'on vide on
a un petit peu de mal à recruter en ce
moment bon bah j'espère que ce sera pas
ça j'espère que la crise va se terminer
dans l'est dans les prochains mois et
qu'on va retrouver la normale et un
fonctionnement classique dans les
prochaines semaines prochains mois on
essaie les aqua l'attractivité au
surcroît de travail liée à la crise oui
il ya eu un surcroît de travail acquis à
la crise très clairement ce qui tire à
qui tu arrives dans un secteur qui était
déjà tendue en terme de 2,2 de
recrutement dans tous les secteurs en
sort dans le public soit dans le privé
ou en ville et on arrivait avec cette
situation de crise qui tend évidemment
le secteur et donc du coup il forcément
le secteur est bien plus tendu que
quelques amants et c'est difficile mais
voilà on essaie de tenir le coup et
j'espère qu'on voit le le bout du tunnel
ça
passe en israël actuellement merci
beaucoup en tout cas merci d'être venu
sur ce plateau et kevin malacarne avec
vous nous parler de votre profession
donc infirmiers libéral et du dépôt donc
devant le conseil d'état de ses 3000
soignants sur leurs revendications
salariales merci infiniment
[Musique]